[Music]
it's starting to get cold outside which
means you probably want to give
everybody blankets and cider and just
curl up in front of the netflix you will
log the next few months but soon enough
you're going to have to be outside again
and odds are somebody on your list is
already out there braving the elements
so here's what to get for them starting
with a drone that is finally small
enough to fit in your pocket and cheap
enough that you might actually pay for
that's the DJI Matic pro the foldable
flyable camera that you almost can't
destroy if you try emphasis on almost if
you're looking for one drone that can go
with you from the starter to pro this is
the one to go for outdoorsy people also
tend to be fitness focused people which
gross but still they'd probably love an
Apple watch which is an excellent
fitness tracker the latest version has
GPS and you can even swim with it plus
it looks a lot nicer than your average
wristband or chest strap just make sure
you find a nice way to give it to them
that doesn't say hey you look like you
could use a few more steps once they've
gotten their 10,000 steps in on a long
hike they're going to want to kick back
with a nice beverage you can even do
that in the cool outdoorsy way with Pats
backcountry beverages it looks like a
futuristic nalgene bottle and it works
sort of like a SodaStream for beer or
soda or really anything carbonated it's
not the best drink they've ever had but
it'll taste just right at the top of the
mountain so when you're in nature you
still need music right pack up the Bang
& Olufsen beoplay a one the tiny disc of
a bluetooth speaker and attach it to a
tree or a tent or something it's a
campsites worth of sound in a tiny
package they won't actually mind lugging
around speaking of lugging stuff around
so you're going to give somebody all
this stuff and they're gonna need a way
to carry it herschel supply has a bag
and backpack that are basically the
definition of rugged they use a
self-healing waterproof fabric that can
literally heal itself if you poke a hole
in it so it can't stand up to a machete
fine but it can handle almost anything
else these things like all the best gear
won't get in the way of anybody's
awesomely outdoorsy lifestyle they'll
just make it more fun and if you don't
want to get up off your couch all that
drone footage is gonna make you feel
like you were there anyway it's a
holiday miracle